bon il peut y avoir en cas de
manifestation des choses très viriles on
est d'accord on est d'accord on constate
mais là avec la volonté de blesser voire
de tuer et notamment par l'usage
l'utilisation des fameux mortiers
d'artifice qui ont été qui ont servi
de on appellerait ça en milieu militaire
de lance de je cherche le nom j'ai
oublié ça m'a passé pardon non non non
non enfin bon peu importe chacun
comprendra bien ce que je veux dire
et et ça ça semble est très nouveau
plutôt par rapport à ce qui s'est passé
en 2005 où
euh enfin essentiellement par rapport à
2005 donc votre regard que vous avez
porté par votre caméra sur les
événements post 2005 ou plus récemment
en 2017 pour vous monsieur Diara est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui euh vous feriez la même
chose vous regarderiez des choses de la
même manière ou est-ce que vous voyez
les mêmes événements qui sont à
l'origine de ces de de ces événements
voilà est-ce que je suis clair je suis
pas sûr mais en tout cas on essaie de
comprendre et puis je voulais vous dire
que sur oui tout à l'heure vous parliez
des renseignements généraux
effectivement mais ce sont les
événements de 2015 qui font que sont
remis en place ce qu'on appelle le
renseignement territorial et finalement
et qui est reconstitué et et qui
aujourd'hui fonctionne voilà ben je sais
pas dans l're que vous voulez monsieur
dufreine
alors je vais essayer de j'ai pris
beaucoup de notes je vais essayer d'être
rapide al on a du papier on a du papier
ouais non mais c'est bon j'ai mon carnet
maintenant euh alors d'abord je voudrais
quand même vous dire que il faut pas
minimiser 2005 2005 c'est 3 semaines
2005 c'est 80 départements sur 100 c'est
pas exactement ce que vous nous avez dit
c'est l'état d'urgence qui est décrété
par Dominique de Villepin contre
d'ailleurs la vie de Nicolas Sarkozi
état d'urgence qui n'était pas pas
arrivé depuis 61 en France 1961 en
France l'Algérie la guerre d'Algérie
hein c'est c'était ça la référence donc
il faut c'est vrai que c'est loin mais
il faut se rappeler qu'en réalité
c'était absolument considérable et
toutes les questions auxquel on va
essayer de répondre en fait elles sont
elles se posaient déjà en 2005 c'est
pour ça que je pense que le le parallèle
est à faire il y a effectivement des
distinction à à à à mener alors vous
vous disiez au début c'était pas
tellement contesté Z desbouna si c'était
contesté puisque on on nous expliquait
queil y avait eu un cambriolage dans un
cabanon de de de de chantier et que
c'était des des jeunes délinquants qui
avaient fui et cetera enfin ça a été
extrêmement extrêmement compliqué
d'avoir la la vérité en revanche il n'y
avait pas l'image il n'y avait pas
l'image de de la centrale électrique de
cliché sous boois avec la mort de ces
deux jeunes hommes et les brûlures
gravissimes du trisè qu'on oublie
toujours mutine il y avait pas l'image
donc il y avait un flou autour autour de
ça euh vous
disiez il y avait plus de violence en
2023 c'est revenu plusieurs fois là je
je crois que vous avez raison en effet
l'intensité de la violence d'après les
rapports de police qu'on a pu qu'on a pu
voir ou les témoignages là il y a pas il
y a y a il y a pas à dire il se trouve
Queen 2005 la seule fois où une arme à
feu est sortie c'était à Grini justement
je suis désolé et ça avait fait la Une
de Paris Match mais ça avait été un
événement ça avait été la preuve ça
avait été la Une de Paris Match on est
en 2005 et en fait la première fois où
des policiers vont essuyer des tirs et
c'est très important de de des mtiers
c'est en 2007 à villier- Lebelle et
c'est à partir de là que les policiers
dans les quartiers vont être doté de
flashball qu'on appellerait aujourd'hui
LBD ça c'est extrêmement important
important parce que ça modifie
considérablement le maintien de l'ordre
et les rapports police population et
cetera et en effet en 2023 il semblerait
qu'il ait des armes à feu qui a été
brandies qui a été sortis par par
certains émetiers ça reste extrêmement
de la Ve même des services de
renseignement dont vous parliez très
faible par rapport aux armes dont on
nous dit je crois avec raison qu'elles
peuvent circuler dans certaines cités en
fait elles ne sont pas sorties de la
même manière que les les agriculteurs
n'ont pas sorti leur de
chasse récemment c'estàd qu'il y a au
niveau le niveau de la violence il faut
toujours le le le mettre par
rapport comment dire au rapport de force
qui est qui qui existe sur euh
l'identification vous avez dit à
plusieurs reprises en 2005 comme en 2023
les émetiers au départ s'identifient
soit zbouna soit Anael et dans un
deuxième temps non et vous vous
interrogez légitim sur pourquoi à ce
moment-là pour reprendre votre
expression ça bouge dans un certains
quartiers et pas dans d'autres bah tout
simplement parce que le rapport de force
justement il est il est il est différent
c'est-à-dire que l'étincelle a déclenché
un incendie et que cet incendie le temps
euh de de sa propagation il est en
partie tenu par les émetiers il y a plus
besoin d'avoir de slogan euh pour dire
et bien nous nous exprimons notre colère
tout le monde n'exprime pas une colère
on est bien d'accord mais pourquoi
voudriez-vous que ça s'arrête alors que
justement le feu a
pris ce qui m'étonne en fait c'est c'est
c'est de de ne pas comprendre que ce qui
est à l'œuvre c'est quand même une si
vous ne voulez pas mettre de mots
politiques si vous voulez pas dire que
ce sont des slogan ou des revendications
c'est quand même l'expression d'une
exaspération d'un sentiment
d'injustice c'est pas de l'amusement
alors opportunité
oui il y a des gens qui ont piqué des
téléphones ou des ou ou des télévisions
pour aller les revendre mais il y a
aussi des mères de famille qui ont volé
du papier
toilette du papier
toilette ça vous dit le le le l'état
social de de la dans dans lequel nous
sommes aller voler du papier toilette
qu'est-ce qui reste bon euh alors sur le
maintien de l'ORD me lancez pas
là-dessus mais je crois que vous avez
reçu Fabien jaobard et Sébastien rocher
qui sont vraiment d'éminemment
d'éminents euh d'éminents spécialistes
mais est-ce que ça augmente le désordre
euh j'ai beaucoup aimé cette question
philosophique j'ai fait un film
là-dessus
euh ce que l'on peut dire c'est et on
l'a vraiment vu euh euh ces derniers
jours avec un nouveau changement de de
doctrine de maintien de l'ordre dès lors
que le ministère de l'Intérieur dit on
n'envoie pas des CRS sur des gens qui
souffrent euh il n'y a quasiment pas de
problème de violence et c'est en gros ce
que Fabien jaobard a dû vous expliquer
ou Sébastien rocher avec la doctrine
dite de la désescalade allemande hein
c'est-à-dire que on revient à un système
à l'ancienne qui était d'ailleurs un
petit peu celui de 2005 hein des parce
que il faut aussi rappeler que du côté
des émetiers en 2005 il n'y a pas
d'éborniers de mains arraché de
mort en dehors de Naël et et de zadbuna
enfin en dehors de zboun en 2005 il y a
pas eu de mort pendant les émeutes il y
en a eu à
Marseille donc le niveau de violence il
est il est il est il est aussi là euh h
h hop Grini ça j'ai voilà euh alors
pourquoi certaines villes euh perpignon
pas
perpignon à l'époque de de 2005 il y
avait eu une énigme une énigme totale
qui était Marseille 2e ville de France
pas d'meut il y en a eu cette année
enfin en 2023 dans le centre-ville de de
de Marseille mais pas dans les quartiers
on a eu et je crois que personne n' été
capable de bien expliquer pourquoi on a
eu des des explications en disant bah à
Marseille dans les quartiers nord on
voit la mer alors on se révolte pas euh
à Marseille on va pas se révolter parce
que c'est la concurrence Paris Marseille
donc on ne va pas objectivement je n'en
sais rien et je pense qu'il faudrait
travailler à Perpignan avec des
travailleurs sociaux pour essayer de
comprendre euh pourquoi à tel endroit ça
a bougé ou ou pas bougé il y a des
paramètres extrêmement euh compliqué il
peut y avoir des rivalités entre les
quartiers il peut y avoir des rivalités
entre les villes qui peuvent soit euh
jouer un caractère d'émulation soit au
contraire euh de de
d'annulation le le le le rôle des images
et ensuite il y aura l'en rue et puis je
te je te laisserai là je vous laisserai
la parole euh euh le rôle des images bah
évidemment il est central mais si nous
faisions un retour en arrière nous
parlerions des JT nous parlerions des JT
de France 2 de TF1 à tel point que nous
apprendrions par la presse que on a
demandé à France Télévision qui sera
suivi par LCI et par TF1 à l'époque je
suis rédacteur en chef de iTélé petite
chaîne d'information alors il a rien a
rien à voir avec ce ce qu'elle est
devenu et je me souviens que un moment
donné le téléphone a sonné en disant
arrêtez avec le palmarès chaque soir
arrêté avec le palmarès du nombre de
voitures brûlées du nombre de
commissariat attaqués du nombre de de
d'arrestations et cetera et donc à
l'époque on a CNN qui débarque qui fait
des cartes extraordinaires en mettant
Strasbourg à Varsovie l'île à
Montpellier enfin c'était je vous assure
je vous invite à aller voir ces cartesl
où on nous expliquait que il n'y avait
pas de raison sociale que c'était
simplement la soif de reconnaissance la
soif de l'image qui animait les émetiers
qu'elle les anime comme ça anime toute
la société je veux dire toute la la
société est traversée par l'idée que il
y a des caméras qu'on veut être beau à
la caméra qu'on veut avoir le plus de
followers possible c'est à tous les
niveau des ministres aux émeotiers donc
c'est un ensemble de la société qu'on
doit interroger par rapport à ça mais
surtout surtout croire comme l'a dit
Emmanuel Macron que les émeutes c'est
les jeux vidéos et les réseaux sociaux
c'est vraiment faire acte de mon point
de vue d'irresponsabilité et enfin pour
la rénovation urbaine vous avez 1000
fois raison après 2005 il y a beaucoup
d'argent qui a qui est arrivé dans les
dans les quartiers on a rénové beaucoup
de quartiers ça fait même l'objet de de
film bâtiment 5 de de la jli par exemple
qui raconte la destruction d'un bâtiment
il y a eu effectivement les les les 12
milliards dont vous parlez c'est
beaucoup moins que l'argent qui est
injecté pour les Jeux Olympiques qui
vont durer 3 semaines enfin passons en
effet il y a eu une une rénovation
urbaine et je je pense que mon mon mon
acolyte sera plus précis que moi mais
semble-t-il on a changé les bâtiments on
n pas changé la vie des gens ça c'est le
premier point et le deuxième
point en juillet 2023 la presse
s'interroge qu'est-ce qui se passe
pourquoi il y a ces immeuves et je
voudrais juste vous citer très très très
vite de deux phrases l'une de Jean-Louis
borlot pas la peine de de le présenter
qui nous dit quand ça a commencé à aller
mieux au milieu des années 2010 on a
arrêté de s'occuper des banlieux ce
n'était plus un problème un peu plus bas
dans le même article un ex-préfet de scè
saint-enis dont on n' pas le nom mais on
peut deviner assez facilement qui il est
nous dit cette chose extrêmement
importante il nous dit en fait une
génération aura été sacrifiée les 15 17
ans c'està-dire les émeutiers qui
constituent le gros des émeutiers sont
les oubliés de la politique de la ville
c'est-à-dire qu'au moment où on a baissé
euh la politique de rénovation urbaine
d'égalité des chances et cetera et
cetera c'est une génération qui qui sort
quelques temps plus tard et ça c'est un
ancien préfet de SC saintny c'est
Jean-Luc borlau qui le
disent moi je vais je vais pas être très
très long parce que beaucoup de choses
ont été dites par Monsieur dufreen avec
lesquels je suis totalement d'accord et
je pense que j'aurais sûrement mis le
point
dessus en ce qui concerne les images il
est vrai qu'en alliance euh du son et de
l'image on peut influencer et manipuler
beaucoup de personnes ça c'est c'est
évident qu'on le fasse de manière
professionnelle comme Monsieur dufine et
moi via le cinéma ou par les réseaux
sociaux avec tel que TikTok Instagram et
cetera et c'est vrai qu'il y a eu
beaucoup de de de personnes dans la
révolte qui ont été opportuniste qu'on
saccageit des magasins qu'on par la même
occasion fait beaucoup de mal aux
personnes qui tenaient ces magasinsl euh
mais comme dans tout mouvement comme
dans toute revendication il y a une
minorité malheureusement euh de fraude
si je peux appeler ça comme ça de fraude
d'opportuniste de
euh pour ce coup là des gens qui sont
pas amoureux de justice et c'est une
minorité malheureusement qui fait
beaucoup de bruit parce que parfois on
leur tend le micro et c'est peut-être la
minorité qui intéresse le plus et euh et
il y a eu beaucoup de bêtises hein
j'étais le premier au fusqué en voyant
certains saccage certaines exactions euh
qu'on n'accepte pas et qui
malheureusement entachche la mémoire de
Naël euh et de toutes les personnes qu'
ont perdu la
vie via les violences policières donc
oui c'est quelque chose à dénoncer c'est
sacage mais je pense qu'il est important
de recentrer la question sur mais
qu'est-ce qui a amené ces violences en
fait la base de du pourquoi du comment
de ces violences bah c'est une
déshumanisation euh de d'une partie de
la population euh de l'injustice à tout
va de la brutalité policière le fait de
considérer certaines personnes comme des
citoyens de 2 3e 4e voir 5e zone c'est
tout ça en fait qui eu euh font que
voilà on a un cocktail sans voilà faire
de mauvais jeux de mots mais on a un
cocktail Molotov en face et et à un
moment donné ça explose et euh et c'est
c'est regrettable parce que encore une
fois euh sans être redondant beaucoup de
personnes et c'est l'immense majorité
veulent vivre en paix en France et ces
violences là sont dénoncé c'est vrai
dans un premier temps par ces habitants
des banlieux mais ça va au-delà et la
France le monde entier a vu que ce
problème des violences policières c'est
vrai de Prim àord touche on va dire les
population dites maghrébine
noiraricaine voilà mais elle a touché
aussi des Caucasiens des blancs on l'a
bien vu avec le mouvement des gilets
jaunes et euh avec voilà des mains
arrachées des gens avec etborniers et
tout ce qui va avec et c'est pour
montrer à quel point ce fléo là euh il
faut le dénoncer il faut le combattre et
ce qui peut en fait les les les
violences policières c'est juste
l'extension de d'unun d'un système qui
est de base très très violent raciste je
vais le dire raciste parfois négrophobe
parfois antisémite islamophobe c'est
tout ça en fait c'est
tout ça qui ont engendré ce monstre que
sont les violences policières donc c'est
important de de de de parler de ça en ce
qui concerne les rénovations je vais je
vais aborder moins de points parce que
il y a il m'a il m'a mché le travail et
et je suis totalement d'accord en ce qui
concerne les rénovations sans manquer de
respect à toutes les personnes à la
jeunesse de ces rénovations
h c'est pas en mettant un coup de
peinture que ça y est c'est bon les gens
vont être heureux désolé hein si vous le
prenez mal mais mais euh il faut que ce
soit beaucoup att merci il faut que ce
soit plus profond en fait enfin euh il y
a la question du logement la question du
travail la question de des perspectives
d'émancipation pour ces personnes c'est
tout ça en fait rénover une façade
h c'est bien et euh il faut saluer le le
travail mise en place par par les villes
mais euh il faut accentuer le le le le
travail et et accompagner ces personnes
plus profondément si je peux dire ça
comme ça parce que la considération elle
ne change pas quand on regarde bien
c'est toujours les les les mêmes
problèmes qui reviennent le logement le
travail et cetera
euh ensuite
euh ce que je voulais
dire les violences policières les
brutalités
policières c'est c'est cyclique en fait
c'est périodique c'està dire il y a des
moment où ça va être calme comme il l'a
dit excusez-moi monsieur
dufine de 2010 à je sait plus quelle
année on va dire c'est c'est plutôt CME
puis après ça revient parce que euh
comme dans dans toute choses il y a il y
a il y a il y a un pic en fait 2005 2007
2023 l'année dernière avec naë il y a il
y a des pics il y a il y a des des des
des interrogations de la frustration de
la
colère qui font que ça explose et euh
enfin voilà c'est c'est pas encore une
fois c'est pas par joie que ces
personnes se révoltent vont créer leur
colère dans la rue ou quoi que ce soit
c'est il y a un ralbol qui est partagé
que ça déplaise à à beaucoup de
personnes mais c'est un ralbol qui est
partagé par l'immense majorité des
Français pas que les noirs et les Arabes
et je pense c'est ça le plus important à
retenir c'est que il faut apporter une
solution à cette question euh des
violences policière comme ça ça
permettra de faire en sorte qu'on sorte
un peu de cette situation de poudrière
dans laquelle on est en France depuis
un moment voilà ce que je peux dire dans
les
médias merci alors qui veut s'exprimer
encore on n pas répondu à la questionur
ah allez-y allez-y allez-y alors
Monsieur duf j'ai oublié sur la sur la
désillusion est-ce qu'il y aurait donc
si j'ai bien compris une forme de
désillusion de la part de de certains
citoyens vis-à-vis de la République
c'est ça est-ce que vous disiez c'est ce
que semble montrer les les études il y a
une différence il y a une différence en
tout cas entre les descendants
d'immigrés allemands en l'espèce les
descendants d'immigrés français d'un
côté on a une intégration je dis pas qui
est facile forcément en Allemagne mais
qu'elle se fait dans des moins mauvaises
conditions alors que en France on a une
définition de la République de l'égalité
à travers par exemple l'accès à l'école
et cetera et en fait il y a une
désillusion par rapport au message par
rapport à ce message républicain quand
on voit sa situation
réelle alors moi je je vous donnerai que
des que des chiffres qui répondent mais
sur le sentiment sur la désillusion le
désenchantement et le détachement je
pense que Monsieur Diara sera plus plus
à même que moi j'ai j'ai j'ai je suis
allé chercher les chiffres de l'INC de
2023 c'estàdire au moment des des des
émeut 1514 quartiers prioritaires de la
politique de la ville le taux de
pauvreté est trois fois plus élevé il
est de 43 % que dans le reste des unités
urbaines trois fois plus élevé le taux
de chômage il est de 18,6 % c'est entre
2 et 3 % 3 fois plus que le reste et
surtout surtout les enfants plus de la
moitié des enfants qui vivent vivent en
situation de pauvreté 57 % des enfants
vivent sous le seuil de pauvreté dans
ces quartiers contre 21 % ce qui est
déjà énorme dans le reste de la France
donc comment voulez-vous avoir la
moindre
illusion quand vous vivez dans ces dans
ces
conditions avant même d'avoir des
désillusions pouvez-vous avoir des
illusions je ne connais pas la situation
allemande mais sur la situation
française ça paraît très
clair le séparatisme il est là la
ségrégation elle est
là et c'est lin qui le
dit pardon allez-y
allez-yz-y c'est très de de en fait le
la merci beaucoup ou j'ai une carte là
de c'est très difficile de rêver en tout
cas la la possibilité de rêver chez
certains elle est coupé très tôt moi des
10 ans ça a été compliqué de de de
pouvoir croire aveuglément en
l'institution qui est la police et et la
France en règle générale mais bien
évidemment de part ma famille et les
gens qui étaient qui sont toujours
autour de moi on on a espoir de de
pouvoir vivre comme il se doit comme
tout le monde même si
voilà le racisme sera toujours là il y
aura toujours des problématiques mais
euh il y aura toujours moyen de de de de
viser
eu une vie meilleure voilà mais puis il
faut que je donne suite à mon prénom qui
dans les langues moningues veut dire
espoir donc si je suis défétiste c'est
pas je vais ça va pas être possible mais
c'est vrai que pour certains et
certaines la la la la la possibilité de
croire en les institutions elle est
coupé très tôt donc voilà pourquoi il y
a ce sentiment de défiance et ce
sentiment de de rejet et c'est là comme
l'a dit monsieur dufren qui a le le vrai
séparatisme en fait et c'est la base de
une des bases en tout cas de de de
certaines
problématiques merci alors madame
Mercier m' demander la parole oui merci
monsieur le Président je je partage ce
que vous dites à la base c'est
l'éducation comment élever nos enfants
élever nos jeunes dans l'amour de cette
république mais c'est vrai qu'on peut on
a des prismes différents mais moi il a
quelque chose que je n'arrive pas à
comprendre si je prends le département
de son etloire la ville de chal sursne
la grosse ville avec vraiment des
quartiers prioritaires il n'y a
absolument rien nu vous descendez de 60
km à Macon il y a eu des dégâts
considérabl des émeutes vous remontez au
nord dans le bassin minier des dégâts
considérables j'ai auditionné l'équipe
municipale ils étaient en pleur ils
allaient dans les quartiers la
médiathèque a été en feu et personne ne
comprend pourquoi en fait c'est ça
pourquoi la précarité et malheureusement
elle est égale partout dans ces trois
pôles que je viens de vous citer
pourquoi deux pôles ont été vraiment
l'objet de violence inouie et pourquoi
pas la ville de Chalon
sursun merci euh je prends la main cette
fois-ci euh mais moi je pense euh tout
simplement madame euh que le rapport
entre la police et les habitants n'est
pas le même partout en fait même s'il y
a des qutier dans votre
ville la brutalité policière bref les
les les relations qu'ont les personnes
habitant dans les quartiers que vous
avez cité et par exemple grenny ou
nanter c'est pas c'est pas du tout les
mêmes moi je suis persuider que ça peut
être l'explication du pourquoi du
comment ça n'a pas été
incandescent dans dans dans certains
endroits et il faut s'en réjouir en fait
moi je suis content vraiment
je faut pas qu'il ait tout le temps des
problèmes quoi c'est c'est c'est c'est
très bien de de de de se réjouir de ça
et et peut-être de de s'inspirer de ces
endroits et savoir bah comment le
dialogue est instauré la confiance et
tout ce qui va avec quoi moi je pense
c'est pour ça que parfois dans certains
endroits c'est le braser et dans
d'autres noms
voilà merci est-ce que sil y a pas
d'autrre prise de parole est-ce
que on on peut dire c'est une question
que ce que vous constatez post 2005 ce
que vous avez dit tout à l'heure
finalement n'a pas varié comme vous avez
lu le le rapport tout à l'heure mais que
par contre
l'intensité de la violence au sens large
du terme là par contre a nettement
progressé et et et enfin moi je suis
convaincu de ça la question est de
savoir le pourquoi est-ce que vous
l'expliquez
notamment par le fait que les gens ou
les les habitants de certains quartiers
ou ou pas seulement des quartiers
d'ailleurs parce que faut pas faire une
généralité sur les quartiers on vient de
le voir la situation personnelle et la
difficulté individuelle ou collective
d'une partie de la population fait
que l'espoir est pas là quoi pour faire
pour utiliser un très grand mot l'espoir
est pas là et que du coup ben la révolte
est d'autant plus
forte
je je oui je je suis absolument
convaincu que le l'intensité de la
révolte et indexé sur l'intensité du du
désespoir ça me semble ça me semble
évident mais il y a quelque chose
d'important c'est que les quartiers ont
de la mémoire les émetiers pas forcément
puisque la plupart n'étaient pas né en
2005 donc voilà et même s'ils parlent de
leurs grands frères ce serait presque
leur père quasiment mais n'empêche que
ils ont de la mémoire et cette mémoire
c'est quoi c'est un ministre monsieur
borlot qui démissionne euh parce qu'il
dit moi on me donne pas les moyens euh
parce que je vous ai donné les chiffres
sociaux et de travail et cetera je veux
dire il c'est c'est c'est un moment
d'exaspération qui est extrêmement fort
et par ailleurs on a aussi vu une police
beaucoup plus violente qu'en 2005 on a
vu des services de police qui n'ont rien
à faire eux-mêmes le disent à mot caché
dans le monde et et autres n'ont rien à
faire dans le dans le dans le maintien
de l'ordre ce sont très très mal
comportés je pense notamment en raid et
au GIGN à Marseille c'est eux qui ont
provoqué des des des morts et
blessés il y a une intensité policière
extrêmement forte qu'on avait pas connu
en
2005 pour pour pour faire des émeutes
faut être deux en fait c'est comme les
manifestations et il faut vraiment avoir
en tête me semble-t-il enfin tous les
travaux sociologiques dignes de ce
nom démontrre dans une démocratie et
dans un moment qui n'est pas un moment
révolutionnaire ça et ça n'est pas un
moment révolutionnaire c'est l'État qui
détermine le niveau de violence on on en
a eu un exemple très clair avec les les
les les agriculteurs il y a 10 jours
qu'on avait pas vu depuis 20
ans donc ce serait ça ma réponse je ne
crois pas que ce soit que des les jeunes
soient plus violents que les arm à feu
soit plus plus accessible elles sont
quasiment pas sorties et cetera je crois
que c'est plus sur les deux raisons que
je vous ai
donné je ou après je je vous laisse
reprendre la main mais et je rajouterai
Internet les réseaux sociaux vraiment ça
a été le vecteur aussi de de de
l'escalade des deux côtés hein que soit
des émetiers des des des révoltés et de
la police aussi quand on voit euh en
manifestation ou euh lors d'une
intervention policière l'intensité euh
des répressions bon euh le soir même ou
le lendemain quand les révoltés
répondent euh ils ont envie de répondre
face à à ce qui a été proposé en face et
vice-versa en fait donc c'est vrai que
les réseaux sociaux internet euh a été
un vecteur pour moi des deux côtés voilà
monsieur dufreen vous avez le mot de la
fin écoutez euh ceux qui ont eu des
déclarations sédiicieuses ceux qui ont
eu des déclarations euh guerrière ce
sont certains syndicats de police
rappelez-vous le communiqué euh qui a
suivi le la mise en détention du tueur
présumé enfin du du meurtrier présumé de
de de naë
euh communiqué
sédutieux notamment d'alliance mais pas
seulement de ce qu'on appelle le bloc
syndical et communiqué qui n'a pas été
dénoncé comme il aurait dû par le
ministre de l'Intérieur et là alors moi
mon mon prénom c'est pas espoir alors je
je vais je je vais être un peu un peu
désespéré c'est-à-dire que si on laisse
les syndicats de police prendre le
pouvoir sur le pouvoir si on laisse les
identitaires de tout bord prendre le
pouvoir sur les quartiers je pense
notamment aux descentes de l'extrême
droite à crépole euh si on laisse ceci
alors dans Comment à Lion bien sûr mais
là à Crépol parce que si c'est quelque
chose qui qui était un peu de cet ordre
là céit un peu comme une une revanche
euh fasciste sur sur sur sur les émeutes
euh il y avait il y avait quelque chose
de cet
ordre-là si euh les institutions ne
prennent pas acte de ce qui est en train
de se passer alors en
2030 je serai pas là pour vous dire 2023
c'est comme 2005 2030 c'est comme 2023
je veux dire là il y a quelque chose
d'extrêmement important et la la me
semble-t-il la base c'est le social
c'est le travail alors évidemment ça
coûte plus cher évidemment c'est moins
comment dirais-je moins démonstratif que
de dire il faut plus de bleu dans la rue
mais c'est infiniment plus
profond merci messieur merci de votre
présence ce matin on renouvelle nos
excuses pour le retard du début de cette
audition et puis merci aux collègues qui
sont restés jusqu'au bout bien écoutez
nous rendrons le rapport au mois de mars
évidemment quand la Commission en aura
débattu il vous sera
adressé merci beaucoup merci merci à
vous merci La Réunion est suspendue
chers collègues bon
appétit